in a new interview with apple music's
zane lowe
singer sam smith revealed they would
like children by the age of 35
saying i want to have kids i want to be
with the kids and i want to watch them
grow
and be with them every day i want to be
money
and although children are in the near
future sam also says
this does not mean the end of their
career saying
i've still got ambition i try to settle
it down all the time
and play it down but i'm ambitious and i
would still want to sing to people and
do this job
it's an amazing feeling sam says being
queer was a major factor
in wanting to inspire others what
created the desire to reach people in
the first place
i think a huge part of it was being
queer you know being young and
i was brought up in a my family were
amazing
with it i came out but i came out when i
was 10 years old
and so i was out as
a as a gay person at 10. at 14 i was
wearing makeup and female clothing
all throughout school so i was i was so
out of the closet for such a long time
that all of that time was was was
loneliness time as well because
i had no one around me that thought like
me who
who was openly gay around me at all in
my life um until i was 19
20 when i became well known just that
feeling i think that all queer kids have
when the when they're younger you know
you're brought up in a world where
you're told that it's not okay to be
what you are
and that's really really hard and sam
addressed the difficulty
that still exists being queer in the
entertainment industry
it's very obvious i think in front of us
that we're not we're not where we should
be and there's stories that aren't being
told and
chances that aren't being given to
people because people aren't ready for
it maybe yet
and uh maybe it's not where the money is
you know that's the truth of it i'm
finding it hard sometimes to navigate
myself through it because you
sometimes one can feel like their dreams
are capped because of
because of their their expression and
who they are
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos